حركه تجاريه متزايده في اسواق وفنادق
بورتودان
انعشها الرعايه الاجانب الذين فروا من
القتال في الخرطوم ادت الى زياده اسعار
السلع اثر زياده الطلب عليها يعني
كل ماشيه زايده تتضاعف كل ما يوم انه
الاسعار ما تتضاعف اكثر واكثر وحركه
الطبيعي بجد اقوى بكثير من الاول نسبه
البيع حتى حاليا بقت مئه في المياه ورغم
الطاقه الاستيعابيه المحدوده للفنادق في
المدينه الا ان ملاك الفنادق يؤكدون عدم
زياده اسعار الاقامه هي مؤسسه ربحيه
تجاريه ولكن الاسعار المعمول بها في خدمات
الغرف وفي الايواء هي نفس الخدمات هي نفس
الاسعار اللي كانت قبليه سنه او سنتين
تقريبا لم يطرح عليها اي زياده نتيجه لهذه
الاحداث رغم التقدس الكبير جدا
اذا كانت تشهد ركودا اقتصاديا قبل اشتعال
الصراع الحالي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات